demain cela fera 100 jours que la guerre
a commencé en ukraine c'est vers
audonienne ce que pourrait tomber d'un
moment à l'autre les russes se
resserrent leur emprise sur cette ville
d'udon basse et on vous retrouve dans
l'est du pays de natal wolch bonjour
vous êtes notre envoyé spécial avec
amaral à mehdaoui et vous avez rencontré
des combattants étrangers ils sont venus
combattre du côté de l'armée ukrainienne
certains ont témoigné à visage découvert
c'est assez rare
oui absolument c'était un accès assez
rare qui nous a été offert aujourd'hui
nous avons donc rencontré une unité
entière de volontaires étrangers de
combattants étrangers venus de nombreux
pays du canada des états unis de
belgique de france entre autres du
mexique également et c'est donc une
unité d'une trentaine à peu près de
combattants qui a été intégrée qui a été
intégrée à une unité de la garde
nationale ukrainienne et ce tournage a
eu lieu après avoir eu l'autorisation du
commandant de cette unité de la garde
nationale nous avons pu notamment
échanger sur sur leurs motivations et
tous d'ailleurs disent à peu près la
même chose sur les raisons qui les ont
poussés à venir s'engager ici en ukraine
ils disent que en voyant ce qu'il se
passait ici en voyant les pertes
l'offensive russe qui ne cessé
d'accroître sa poussée avec une extrême
violence un peu partout en ukraine ils
se sont sentis obligés de venir de
s'engager beaucoup de ces volontaires de
ces combattants étrangers ont un passé
militaire on a notamment échangé avec
deux américains qui étaient tous les
deux tous les deux dans l'armée
américaine l'un d'entre eux a été
déployé en afghanistan dans les années
2010 et ils sont aujourd'hui positionnée
dans un endroit qu'on nous a demandé de
de tenir secret dans l'est de l'ukraine
et ils attendent d'être déployés dans
l'est sur les lignes de front de l'est
et notamment évidemment dans le débat
certains ont déjà combattu sur le front
est d'autres attendent encore de
connaître lors leur première expérience
sur
sur le sur le champ de bataille voilà on
attendra donc votre reportage sur cette
unité un peu spécial plus globalement
johnattan quels sont vos informations
sur la situation dans le donbass
écoutez vous avez notamment mentionné ce
cette bataille cruciale
ac v rod au niet nous étions à proximité
de cette ville il ya quelques jours avec
amara lamidat oui pour tourner un
reportage a mis six ans à l'époque les
combats il était déjà très violents
avaient déjà lieu à l'intérieur de la
ville aujourd'hui on sait que les russes
tiennent quasiment la totalité de ses
vers audonien est-ce qu'on voit mal
comment les ukrainiens pourraient
empêcher les russes de prendre
totalement la ville et puis si les
russes y parviennent et bien après il y
aura évidemment d'abord les sites chance
que sur leur route juste juste de
l'autre côté du fleuve d'eau niet
et puis surtout les deux grandes villes
qu'il faudra que les prêtres les russes
prennent s'ils veulent s'emparer de
l'ensemble de la région cram à tort sq
et sauvian mais nous avons pu observer
les défenses les lignes de défense et
les positions ukrainienne dans cette
zone et ils peuvent opposer une
résistance importante pendant un certain
temps on a notamment noté notamment ont
pu voir leur armement ils ont nombreux
lance missiles antichars et de nombreux
blindés qui sont positionnées dans cette
zone merci pour ces éléments john allan
walsh envoyé spécial france 24 avec amar
à la médaille